[Applause]
for charts new military government
this wasn't the start they were hoping
for one week
after they seized power
young chadians on the streets setting
bonfires
and blocking highways
the hurt of this protest is an
opposition to military takeover
together we are tired of monarchy and
chad
we just want france to free us from this
problem
the response of the security forces was
swift and harsh
[Music]
hours later military ruler general
mohammad idris derby
appeared on national television to
deliver what seemed to be a speech
prepared to calm local and international
concerns about the military's
intervention
in chad
these values so dear to our late
president will be demonstrated and
enshrined
in the framework of an inclusive
national dialogue that will be organized
during this transition period i will be
the guarantor of this dialogue which
will not shy away from
any subject of national interest
according to a precise timetable that
the government
will be called upon to reveal he also
said chad needs international support to
defeat groups
trying to destabilize the country the
protest came a week after the military
checkover was given some support by a
child's allies
that has now put france in an awkward
position after
the crackdown on demonstrators by
security forces
the french president emmanuel macron
whose attendance at lake president idris
debbie's funerals
an endorsement of the military's
takeover condemned the use of force
on demonstrators
let me be very clear i gave my support
to the integrity and the stability of
chad very clearly in engine mana
i support peaceful democratic inclusive
transition i do not support a plan of
succession
and france will never be on the side of
those who form this plan
for now the streets of yemen are calm
but there are fears it won't remain that
way
or the opposition vowing to keep up its
campaign against the military regime
muhammad ruiz al jazeera germany